blanc caire pourrait ne pas être tout à
fait dans le bon tempo en effet sa
volonté d'organiser des débats sur
l'écologie dans les lycées vendredi jour
où des milliers d'élèves ont l'intention
d'aller manifester dans la rue pour la
planète peut peut-être faire un flop on
va voir ce que vous en pensez
yannick jadot l'écologiste estime lui
que le ministre de l'éducation a tort de
vouloir sifflet trop vite la fin de la
récré il est tendance blanca je pense
qu'il est nu hésité en disant ça ça sera
deux heures de colle le vendredi après
midi si vous allez manifester soit ce
sera un débat sur le climat
on a une jeunesse extraordinaire elle
est en train de s'emparer de son futur
elle nous dira mais non mais partout
elles n'a dit si on lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique on a un avenir si
on ne lutte pas contre le dérèglement
climatique
gilet jaune gilles hiroshi les verts y
aura plus que des gilets de sauvetage et
y en aura pas pour tout le monde
partager l'enthousiasmé moi j'étais
résolument pour les deux heures de colt
par mois moi ça m'exaspère ces
manifestations s'étaient de démagogie
des jeunes qui nous expliquaient leurs
aînés à vous tuer la planète comme c'est
mal et ses cours de de tri sélectif
confère aux enfants toute la journée
donc moi personnellement sans rien nier
de la réalité de ce phénomène gravissime
cette affaire-là m'exaspère je pense
qu'il fait comme il veut mettre à
l'école pour travailler et que ni de
débattre de ce fossile et vendredi entre
16h et 18h j'en peux plus moi mais vous
non mais alors prétendu pitié creta
sundberg jeune suédoise de 14 ans fut
pas si je comprends sans son ire du
moment parce que cette jeunesse qui
braillent l'empêchent de dormir mais
honnêtement c'est 7
c'est absolument c'est d'abord le
discours de créatine béhague est un
discours qui s'entend qui s'écoute et
qui est extrêmement émouvant que des
gamins de 16 17 18 ans nous montre du
doigt évidemment c'est désagréable
moralité
en fait c'est pas du droit fait un
procès dans sa totalité
avez vous est souffrant et cris mongauzy
jeuniste alors on va expliquer les
années ce qu'on parle de tout et moi je
prends je sais je prêtais les khmers
verts je précise je dénonce et vos
parents je prescris les nôtres a fait du
très rapide aux bills une bonne sieste
on va on va pauvres à 100 il ya
simplement un problème majeur qui
s'appelle le réchauffement climatique
personnes non connect précisément les
détails mais que des gamins de 16 ans
qui par ailleurs elle est surdoué
elle doit avoir 652 cuisse et une gamine
absolument formidable façade ischios
phillies vous nous avez foutu note la
tête en l'air s'il vous plaît qu'est ce
que vous faites pour réparer avant qu'il
ne soit trop tard
ça me paraît pas dément et et ce
mouvement qui s'appelle you for climate
dans lequel j'ai ont retrouve une jeune
belge a tout à fait remarquable qui a 19
20 ans s'appelle à del et de charlier
honnêtement moi je les écoutais c'est
très émouvant
c'est plutôt construits sont pas des
petits crétins qui devrait aller en cour
à prendre s'est construit savent ce
qu'ils disent
il porte une parole et honnêtement je ne
dis pas qu'il faut écouter a été faire
tout ce qu'ils disent à la seconde près
et qu'il ne faut pas faire comme annick
janot de l'arrivée de récup politique de
bas étage
en revanche ce qui pose comme problème
est un problème réel qu'est ce qu'on va
lancer comme planète comme brossard et
qu'il le peut et il porte 7,7
ce cri de manière régulière toutes les
semaines en séchant les cours je dis
bravo et si je peux l'aider il avait
touchera fleury lycée jean moulin
alexis poulain vous serez dans la rue
vendredi oui je serai dans la rue moi je
trouve c'est formidable
c'est les seuls finalement à prendre
l'ampleur de l'enjeu climatique de la
révolution écologique qui doit être là
en fait ça fait 50 ans qu'on a des
constats que on a commencé la coop et 50
ans qu'on nous ment ou qu'on est très
hypocrite sur la façon dont on fait la
politique des petits pas on voit bien
que et pourtant les rapports du giec 1
s'accumulent
les scientifiques sont pas des rigolos
et alertent depuis 50 ans en disant
regardez on court droit à la catastrophe
qu'est ce que vous faites
alors on fait un peu sur le co2 puis on
oublie d'autres choses alors qu'on ait
de la zone va être un autre problème on
fait un peu gênant j'ai bien sûr mais
voilà non mais c'est pas ce genre de
choses qu'il faut faire aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui la protestation de ces
gamins dans la rue elle est ce justement
sur cette question du système
est ce que ce système là est capable de
se transformer et est capable de faire
une transition ou est-ce qu'il faut
complètement arrêté et j'ai passé à
autre chose sinon on n'a pas d'avenir
sinon demain c'est l'air qui serait
respirable et quand l'air est respirable
alors là on aura d'autres soucis que de
savoir s'il faut faire une taxe sur
l'essence ou pas donc je suis content
que ces enfants là prennent la
conscience et et milite comme ça de
cette façon là la question c'est qu'est
ce qui va se passer après c'est marche
parce que évidemment qui vont être
entendus récupérer ce que vous voulez
mais tout ça va pas durer un an ou je ne
sais pas comment ça va ça va continuer
mais ça fait partie de ces petites
révolutions en avez emmanuel macron à se
saisir du migrant d'elbach la nette de
gages si vous voulez mais tout le monde
a essayé de récupérer de faire croire
qu'il entend être élu il ya d'ailleurs
le projet de loi aux prévisions comment
ça s'appelle plus où nos deux invités
sont totalitaires et moi pro-européen
néo nazis ou alexis brézet a totalement
pété l'autre vous ne répondez pas ma
question sur le web
la mairie n'a pas entendu une telle
pression vous posez en tout cas le débat
sur le climat dans les lices et une
bonne idée donc c'est l'initiative de
jean michel blanquer
vous êtes partagés oui à 54% ou
seulement des atouts victis nous dit les
lycéens sont informés qu'ils sont
formatés johan ça ne marche jamais c'est
une trop bonne occasion de sécher oui
bah oui le bourrage nicole bourrage de
crâne des collégiens et lycéens est
devenu insupportable y seront-ils
abandonner leur smartphone parce que
c'est mauvais pour la planète c'est pas
faux brownie tous les grands noise
populaire n'apporte rien par se donner
bonne conscience démographe jean torrent
et bah je vous remercie beaucoup tous
les quatre pour ce beau débat et je vous
propose de nous quitter en musique parce
que là ça va être ça va être un moment
d'écouté goodbye la chine parce que le
batteur qui était s'était illustré dans
ce morceau des beach boys mais aussi qui
avait joué avec frank sinatra nous a
quittés il s'appelait à au bled
il est mort aujourd'hui à l'âge de 90
ans